god it's Monday Catherine and I are in
San Juan Islands for our fifth year
anniversary bring my chair just you made
my peak music we are on our fifth
anniversary vacation yes we are
it's been five years that we've been
married what do you think I could do it
for another five at least so she's in
for another five folks at least five I
don't think that's how marriage works
come come come ask me again another five
years where are we uh we are in
Washington State
trip on San Juan Island this is this you
pay me I love you it is nice it's a nice
place for staying though right do it
again ah ha ha ha ha I want to show you
something he's gone
oh you know it's indicative of how nice
doesn't tell you know how nice a place
is this is the toilet bowl brush if it
were to talk what would it sound like
when we got married what did you think
of me has it changed
no no I mean we were we we we dated for
a long time before I got married so you
know I had a pretty formed opinion of
you what do you think about
nerdfighteria appreciative you also want
me to have more time in my life I love
hanging out with you that's like my
favorite thing to do
No so you're jealous of them a little
bit jealous sometimes
are you enjoying hankgames yeah it's
really fun I love going back and
watching them and seeing like look we
had fun stupid jokes we made I never was
like a person who played video games by
myself even when I was growing up when
we had like the NES yeah it was most fun
when like my friends come over and we
don't play Battletoads it's now to the
point where there are games where you
can play multiplayer that you can't play
local multiplayer you have to play it
online yeah that's sad to me even
watching people like even be watching
Melissa play ocarina of time or Pikmin
or kick Minh yeah
I liked that little worm mm-hmm happy
little guys dying for you
decide that they really like you when
they follow you around throw me out the
thing they just needed a leader
oh very what do you think about fairies
I don't believe you don't believe in
fish oh she doesn't even Vic what about
slugs
well like slugs yeah I didn't know that
I liked love we yeah I hate like the
tiny little garden slugs
let me lay down in the grass and she'll
stand up and they'll be like nine slugs
on her legs but in Washington there's
like these huge
I'll put video of them over this well we
didn't even see like the big like the
Manhattan you were like stroking it so
cool yeah and it was like changing shape
how does it like a transformer
it's got all these different body shapes
yeah different colors and they're really
big and they had like I put touched its
eye and it's I was like war oh really
goal so I really enjoyed meeting the
slugs yeah yeah I got Washington friends
were like yeah they're slugs they're
gross you step on them and it's gross so
it's beautiful here so we're going to go
for a hike now yeah yeah hey thanks for
being married to me thank you for being
married to me
oh I like it John we'll see you on
Wednesday